espérons que samuel ne subissent pas à
un mouvement bâtisse samuel ne subisse
pas le même sort que qui quitte à voir
ton t shirts à mal par la rébellion
le nombre d'e mails que je reçois bien
je fais un état multi coach est rigolo
c'est une donnée définition genevoise a
les yeux fermés impôts je commence aussi
par un gros mot mais est-ce qu'on triche
fondamentale arrêts oui c'est ça
conscient amour oui imposture
ah oui vous pensez ça oui non c'est la
même chose on july c'est la même chose
que les impôts il ya des gens qui
peuvent alors bien calculé dans leurs
oeuvres puis à des gens très riches qui
peuvent en avoir beaucoup parce qu'ils
ont beaucoup liotta c'est pareil il ya
des gens qui peuvent avoir beaucoup de
temps
bof alors ça si c'est l'heure des
comptes que dans le dico il ya me ça
c'est un truc formidable il faut saluer
à un rêve parce que dans le nouveau
petit robert
il ay là il il ya depuis longtemps un
certain nombre de deux mots ayant
notamment 9,9 étoffes et ça c'est quand
même le four j'ai ça dans l'europe ça
s'il m'a choqué c'est extraordinaire ça
ça n'est pas dans le dictionnaire de
l'académie française c'est pas dans le
best seller les académiciens sont jamais
la teuf qui n'ont jamais touché une
moche ils n'ont pas peur des coeurs
battent en battant battant vous dis tout
le temps vous je suis pas battant dès
que ça devient un peu dur je m'arrête
c'est vrai que moi je suis pas un fan de
l'escalier comme qu'il ya un ascenseur
j'en prends jean provencher vous
maintenant qui est très très bien c'est
que le barbu c'est ce que 5 le bar alors
un club marc c'est un goût c'est
artificiel obtenu à la suite d'une
intervention chirurgicale et consistant
à créer une petite poche sous l'abdomen
des fervents du nudisme pour permettre
de conserver leur carte de crédit et
quelques billets de banque sur eux
lorsqu'ils sont venus sur la plage
aurait toujours des phrases comme dans
leur bain des exemples nus sur le sable
nous amusions à lutter soudain une
douleur fulgurante ne transperce à sans
faire exprès mon compagnon de jeu pour
foncer sans plus dans mon pays bas
il est et il est pas mal soudain lui il
est très très drôle parce que c'est un
du c1 du ces c'est un jeune animal très
sautillant mais mieux qu'ils se
promènent dans la campagne
en faisant des cliques hui mia la raison
c'est un quart
eh oui